- Good morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is "believe", and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the major
problems in the world.
So today's message is empower people.
Over to you, Sundar Pichai.
(rooster singing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The thing which attracted me to Google,
and to Internet in general,
is that it's a great equalizer.
And so, to me, always been
struck by the fact that
Google Search worked the same
as long as you had access
to a computer with connectivity,
if you were a rural kid anywhere
or if you were a professor
in Stanford or Harvard.
And to me, I want Google to
strive to push to do that,
not just build technology
for certain segments,
for me it matters that we drive technology
as an equalizing force,
as an enabler to everyone
around the world.
- I think the best thing that you can do
is create a product or
service that empowers people.
That's what we do as entrepreneurs.
We see a problem, we see an opportunity,
we want to make a difference in the world.
We want to make money, yes,
but we want to have an impact,
we want to empower
people, we want the output
that we are creating to touch
people's lives in some way.
And I think that's the
most gratifying thing
that you can do as an entrepreneur,
to know that the thing that you spent
all this time and energy and effort
in putting into the
world is being received,
great, people like it,
but it's empowering them
to do more in their lives
and in their businesses.
It's why my YouTube
channel is so fun for me,
it's so amazing for me to wake up
and see your comments everyday
because I know the work
that I do is empowering,
it allows you to go out and
do, hopefully, amazing things.
I believe that entrepreneurs will solve
every problem in the
world, the major problems.
It's not big corporations,
it's entrepreneurs.
And so, I can help by giving you content,
by giving you inspiration,
by giving you strategies and tactics
to help your businesses become better.
If I play a quarter percent role
in helping you get better
and build your company,
I know it's going to
have a ripple effect out,
and that's why my goal's to
help a billion entrepreneurs,
because if I can touch
a billion entrepreneurs
in a quarter percent way,
that is massive world change.
That's what gets me pumped up,
that's why I love doing what I do.
I want to empower you
guys to do great things.
If I look at this business,
Toronto Dance Salsa,
people come to learn how to dance salsa,
but really they're
coming for other reasons,
they're lonely, they want to meet people,
they're looking for a relationship,
they're looking for some friends,
they're looking to build
their self-confidence.
There's always a deeper
reason for why they come here,
and people always leave feeling
happier with themselves,
feeling more confident, maybe
meeting some new friends.
And that empowers them
in their entire life,
not just in the one hour when they come in
and they learn how to do a turn, right?
We're empowering them
to live a better life
for the rest of their life
because of the time that
they spend in our class.
That's exciting, that's
energizing, so we stand for.
And so, if you are focused on
creating a product or service
that, yes, can make
money, but has an impact
by empowering people to do great things
in their lives and their businesses,
I think that's the ultimate
most satisfying thing
that you can create as an entrepreneur.
So the question I have
for you guys today is,
what are you doing to empower others?
Let me know, let me feel
the passion you got for it.
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout to Imran Dean.
Imran, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "Your One Word".
Really, really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And remember your one word is ...
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of "Entspresso".
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep going
- The traditional reform
mindset towards education is
let's micromanage teachers more.
Like a good number of
really great teachers
are getting handicapped
by this micromanaging,
teaching to the test or whatever else.
And forcing like, "On
Tuesday, September 27
"you have to cover this",
and you can't question that,
"and you have to say it in these words",
and you have no time to
run your own project,
think of your own curriculum
or whatever you want to do.
We generally feel like the teachers
are getting liberated here.
Do what you want everyday
and the students are going to
learn what they want to understand
and we're freeing tons of
class time for you to do
what I think you wanted
to teach to begin with.
Like, when I ran my little summer camp,
I won't claim I have
30 years of experience
and all the rest, but what was fun for me
was not having to give a lecture
on least common multiple,
not having to give a
lecture on probability.
To know that that was out of the way
and getting this super fun simulation
where the kids are trading
piece and all this,
and I got to, I felt like I was able
to express my creativity, I
was able to go home and say,
"What would be a really cool way
"to understand this concept intuitively?"
And when I went to classroom
that's what we did,
and I felt like it was a
much richer experience.
And so, we genuinely feel
and we genuinely hope
that it's doing that for teachers,
and the teachers in Los
Altos have expressed that,
that they love, the they feel liberated,
they feel like they have data
that they never had before.
The fifth-grade teachers
they teach all the classes,
'cause they're elementary school,
and they feel handicapped
in their other classes now
because they are doing that, the lecture,
they are doing the stuff that I would say
is lower value than what they're
doing in their Math classes
which is the projects,
which are the one-on-one interactions.
And so, they're actually asking
us as quickly as possible,
"When are the grammar videos coming?
"When are the grammar exercises coming
"so I can do more interesting things
"with that part of my day in class?"
- I've heard the story
that the first line of code
that you wrote was in an
apartment in Campbell.
- That's right.
- Not too far from here.
- Just down the street. That's right.
- I mean, did you have any idea,
you know, you wrote this, you
put it out on the Internet,
you didn't sort of do it thinking,
"Hey, I'm going to build and
$83-billion-dollar business"?
- No, of course not at all, not at all.
Really, I mean, it was
just this, as I said,
as a software engineer I
wanted to write some tools
that I thought could be
useful to ordinary people,
regular people.
I had a day job, started as a
nights and weekends projects.
And it's amazing, of course
now, we all understand,
code does change the world and
it can change people's lives,
but I think what makes eBay unique,
despite the fact there are many,
so now there are more
marketplace businesses out there,
we are really, have
always been about people.
It's always been about bringing
tools to ordinary people.
And giving them the tools
and the opportunities
that they need, that they can
use to then be successful,
and define success in their own way.
So, yeah, those were really,
those were really weeks
and months for crazy.
So I remember, one of
the first items listed,
this was in 1995, in September 1995,
one of the first items listed was
a 1952 Silver Dawn Rolls-Royce, okay?
And the seller, and I wish
we could find the seller,
the seller was amazing because he, or she,
had done this beautiful listing.
And so, you know, you
could put HTML in there,
the seller had created
this server somewhere
to actually host photos,
back in those days you
had to actually own,
bring your own server to host photos,
and actually had this
beautiful listing in there.
I looked to that and I
said, "This is incredible.
"There is no way anyone will
ever buy a car on the Internet.
"Like, that's just ridiculous.
That will never happen".
Of course, now there's a car sold
every four minutes on a mobile device.
I mean, it's incredible,
it's totally incredible.
So, who could have imagines that?
- How do you motivate
people to get things done?
- You know, the reason why I paused was
I was trying not to come
up with a tried answer.
I think, and this is a
much use, an overused term,
I think defining an overall
goal that's reaching
in that it isn't attainable,
and then empowering,
this is the overused word,
and then empowering people
to actually go try and get it,
and ensuring that when they have a misstep
that you're there to help them along
is probably the way to.
I mean, you know, to be frank with you,
most of the people that we
hired are extremely smart,
they're self-motivated,
they're very hardworking,
and you've got to, much like a racehorse,
you've got to make sure
that you give them the space
to develop and mature and accomplish.
So I think most of my partners
would say the same thing.
I mean, it takes an element of defining
the ultimate destination
and then empowering people
to actually go to achieve it.